freunde ich habe es geschafft ich war
beim friseur und damit herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video auf einem kanal und zwei spielen
wir heute bibi und tina mal wieder das
erste spiel das wir heute spielen heißt
über den fluss ich würde sagen wir
klicken direkt auf zum spiel um an das
andere ufer zu gelangen springe auf die
insel und gegenstände die ok das ist ja
eigentlich relativ selbsterklärend ein
paar sekunden später super geklappt also
wir gehen jetzt mal ein stückchen nach
hier m springen dann mal hier vorne auf
das teil darauf jetzt haben wir fünf
punkte bekommen jetzt springe ich hier
rüber auf die seerose hier wieder rüber
auf die insel nun warten wir hier vorne
auf den holzstämmen der kommt hier vorne
an
es wäre schon kraft wenn sie den sprung
jetzt hier hinkriegt aber kehrte
geschafft und jetzt hier rüber auf die
andere seite da
ach gott es gibt noch nächstes level wie
gibt es jetzt irgendwie so sterne die
man einsammeln muss ja aber jetzt läuft
er gleich schnell was
a-ha hier genau das wollte ich also die
steuerung könnte in der tat ein bisschen
besser sein also wir spielen jetzt
erstmal hierüber hier drauf darüber
direkt wieder darauf wir müssen jetzt
ein bisschen durchziehen weil wir auch
nicht so viel zeit haben jetzt hier auf
die insel da vorne direkt wo das war
irgendwie ist die seerose und jetzt
rüber auf die andere seite da haben wir
das zweite level geschafft das dritte
level ist hier und sagt rüber auf die
andere seite haben dass er will jetzt
auch endlich die sache ist die steuerung
ist er komplett beschissen
guck ich drück darin links wird die
springt einfach hier auf den holzstämmen
dann hier auf die wahrscheinlich das
nächste atemberaubendes spiel was ich
uns hier heute für das video ausgesucht
habe ist küken allah der schaut böse aus
also die tüten sind hier abgehauen und
immer wenn 1 auftauchen müssen wir
draufklicken denn dadurch bekommen die
punkte ich versuche jetzt mal relativ
gut zu sein da hinten sind welche hier
auf den hahn muss nicht drauf klicken
sollte ich auch nicht auf die also das
eichhörnchen auch nicht von alter die
kommt schon schnell hoch hier ich weiß
nicht die betreiber dieser webseite mit
meiner intelligenz und meinem klick
vermögen hier ob die darauf gefasst
waren ob die damit gerechnet haben aber
freunde wir sind schon bei über 500
punkten hier gerade freunde ich will
mich hier wirklich nicht weit aus dem
fenster lehnen aber ich habe jedes küken
bisher mitgenommen und so schnell
a
das spiel
hat sich auf gehangen ich blende euch
mal eben kurz ein ich hatte diese
punktzahl
jetzt hat sich aufgang rechnet das spiel
nicht damit dass man so eine hohe
punktzahl ist no joke ich will mich
jetzt 60 selbst burschen oder so aber
das safe weltrekord safe sonst wäre es
ja nicht abgestürzt
das nächste spiel was wir uns
herausgesucht haben freunde ist fitness
für hoheit das klingt nach spaß also
dieser ziegenbock hier vorne ist ein
wenig hyperaktiv und deswegen müssen wir
jetzt hier über einen hindernisparcours
mit ihm laufen und immer so sachen
ausweichen hier zum beispiel drüber
springen wenn jetzt gleich mal ein vogel
kommt will vielleicht doch mal ein vogel
kommen hier müssen wir jetzt drunter her
genau und wenn so was ist dann müssen
wir da wieder drüber springen das macht
natürlich mega viel spaß das spiel ist
auch sehr anspruchsvoll
das war richtig lukács hat so ein
bisschen ab dass das wohin nicht so
richtig geklappt hat mit dem spiel das
ich hätte schon noch mal ganz gern mal
in spa am ende gesehen und so aber
freundlich man könnte einfach mal bei
google eingeben bibi und tina küken
alarm und mal schauen ob ihr immer ins
korps knackt werde dir ähnlich brauchst
gar nicht probieren 655 punkte habe ich
hier drin jetzt geschafft das kann man
viel viel viel viel besser machen das
nächste spiel das wir heute spielen
werden ist die große pferde show ich
klicke einfach auf weiter hier wird
gezeigt das pferd schmücken kannst das
heißt das ist so ähnlich wie dieses
spiel glaube ich aus dem letzten video
ja will eine grüne kugel eis wtf was der
mit dir falsch gelaufen also zunächst
einmal bekommt er hier eine blaue decke
drauf dann haben wir als sattel denen
hier vorne mit dem schwarzen und als
stützen die braun schwarzen hier das
heißt wir kriegen jetzt mal auf den
pfeil haben das ganze jetzt hier richtig
das nächste fährt bekommt eine
wie nennt man das heißt es nicht h&m
nicht einmal hier unten hat er glaube
ich gar nicht so richtig oder also ich
weiß nicht ich glaube die aok hat im
schwanz hier hinten noch was das soll
aber das nächste feld auch hingekriegt
in den haaren hatte er auch 95 punkte
sind jetzt nicht so gut hilfe wo bleibt
die milch milch ist gift das hier ist
tatsächlich mein absolutes
lieblingsspiel aus der reihe bibi und
tina dafür wurden ja auch zahlreiche
preise vergeben
das heißt hier vorne schneiden wir die
sachen dran an die kühe hier vorne dran
hier hierher ich habe jedoch extra alle
gerade neu daran gemacht also die hier
saugen jetzt auf jeden fall ein bisschen
milch raus hier vorne oder die gehen
einfach mit der zeit selbst aber das ist
das spiel ich glaube dass das wirklich
so gemeint ist dass die alle ab 100 mal
abgeben also hier sagt jetzt gerade
jeder jetzt sind hier aber wieder 2 345
weekend immer einfach dranbleiben
genauso wie wenn jemand video anschaut
können die weiter dran bleiben ja das
ist ja mal ein übelste spiel hier komme
ich pack' die teile dran und dann haften
die anholter hier und an genii woanders
wieder fünf stück ab komme jetzt sind
hier alle dran so kamen und jetzt ich
wiederkommen da direkt wieder abgegangen
war ist das café ok 154 haben wir als
corp hat jetzt ultra viel spaß gemacht
an der stelle wenn ich jetzt allerdings
auch das video hier beende meine damen
und herren wenn euch ist gefällt dass
ich kinder spiele spiele dann erlass
gerne mal ein leichter und bei 50.000
like
vom nächste woche ein weiterer part
kinderspiele mit luca als ihr
kinderspiele kennt die spielen soll
könnte mir die gamer und in die
kommentare schreiben also am besten
wirklich irgendwie sowas stumpf ist was
auf einer website zu spielen gibt wo ich
jetzt nicht in irgendeinen laden gehen
muss und mir eine alte konsole kaufen
muss also ein kreis und jetzt würde ich
an der stelle sonst sagen dass hier
können jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
stecken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon 100 könnt ihr
auf die glocke klicken dann willkommen
die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]